it's Lindsay Lohan
[Applause]
wow looks like we're matching look it's
like we know
you guys
this is my prom fantasy look this is
what my prom should have looked like
right Lindsay welcome I'm so excited
you're here Drew says hi she loves you I
love her too I love you too
it's a Love Fest and how much did you
love seeing that old Duncan Hines
commercial I did not know you guys are
gonna I was like wait what the surprise
we're a little tricky around here
um you know this is like a homecoming
for you you're a New York girl and
you're back home welcome home thank you
yeah
eating but you are no longer here you
moved I live in Dubai and and I love it
there it's beautiful and look at look
what life has brought you since you've
moved yeah you are in a good place
something else we have in common
we just got married we just got married
congratulations
just this summer
um what is married life like
um it's great he's a great man and I
found my partner and you know you never
know if that's going to happen in life
you're so cute and you know you look so
happy thank you I am I am
[Applause]
I get really shy still talking about it
I see that in you why what brings up
that no I think it's the excitement and
and also I feel like when when you have
a partner you become you become like
protective of the two of you in a
different way you know which
um I've I've come into that recently we
got married in April actually it wasn't
the summer well but you let everybody
know in the summer so you kept it a
secret
um yes was it so hard to be like hello
how are you I'm Lindsay Lohan and I'm
not married but I am yeah is that hard
it was the hardest was he proposed to me
on the set of falling for Christmas oh
um not on the set but offset when we
were filming and I did not tell anyone
because I didn't want it to distract
from our work and stuff so I was like
holding in that I was engaged and I'm
getting engaged in the movie yeah and I
was like I can't do this anymore oh yeah
you have to like switch rules which one
am I am yeah well did you know right
away I did I said it to him I was like I
think I'm gonna marry you one day and I
think he thought I was crazy
did you think you were crazy no I felt
it you did yeah I knew it I love how you
look when you talk about him what it's
cute you guys is cute
anyway
and I come back to acting hello so the
lohanasants everybody's talking about
we've missed you Lindsay it's been rough
out here
thank you we have needed you we have
needed you and I've loved you for so
long I think we have forever I mean
Parent Trap let's start there you beat
out thousands of other little kids
I I was thinking about your audition
process and what's what that must have
been like as a little kid like doing the
screen tests and things you ever think
back on those moments yep Parent Trap
was a lot of screen tests
um well I went back I auditioned once
then I got a call back again then I got
a third call back and also I just I
can't imagine what it was like for my
mom because I was running around the
house speaking with a British accent
yeah
and then like singing Madonna and then
going to audition for a movie it's just
probably crazy for her what do you
remember about that I mean Dennis Quaid
across from you what was that like
um I just was just so excited that day I
feel like when I was younger and acting
I had no nerves at all whatsoever and I
think as you get older and then you get
on set like I get really nervous every
day the first day of shooting now yeah
it's like it's good nerves but then I
had no nerves
do you when when you look back I think
we all do this you look at pictures of
yourself as like a little kid you know I
always think God I wish I could tell Lil
Ross something what do you wish you
could tell to Lindsay
um slow down
oh girl
I got it because I think when you're
young and you get excited about things
you move too fast you forget to just
take a minute so that's what I would
tell myself and after the film is
released did you play twins in that
movie is it true that people that came
up to you and asked look at there's two
of you that's so freaky there's two of
you did people think you really were a
twin
um Yes actually at the premiere Michael
Eisner who's at Disney at the time
um he said where's your twin
but he was like a stupid head like the
head yeah yeah he said where's your turn
I was like I don't have a twin you
should have paid me double
and I'll never forget that I actually
said that
that is so great do you ever keep in
touch with Dennis Quaid I do yeah yeah
he's a great guy yeah we're supposed to
do I was supposed to do his podcast but
the time didn't work out because it was
hard with Dubai time I love when uh
stars that work together in movies
actually are friends you know it makes
me feel better because I rewatched the
movie over and over and over again that
you get along like um Jamie Lee Curtis
yeah you guys are still close right
Freaky Friday love that movie
uh she just posted this recently on
Instagram did you see this she posted
this oh she shared another movie and she
said my little girl's all grown up oh
I love her
to have like mentors like that in in the
business what does that mean to like a
young kid coming up Jamie was a big
mentor to me because I was I was I think
I was turning 17 and I was just kind of
girl things were happening and I was on
set and so I needed her to go to and and
so she was really just there for me and
and she's still like that I still look
up to her and I ask her for advice
sometimes and it's I think it's
important to you know connect with the
people that you can relate to on
different levels and and I feel really
lucky enough still ever as a friend yeah
um okay tell me the truth she said she
would do a Freaky Friday sequel can we
just make it happen
are you
down to do it and how quickly can we get
it done I am down to do it yeah of
course
of course I love Disney I love Jamie so
are there conversations actively like
hello how close are we to getting this
done let's sign it let's sign it today I
love to do it and are we talking to
anybody about it well I don't know maybe
sorry
right
[Music]